de nelson's making his third start his
last win was the 25th of july against
the diamondbacks last time out he had a
no decision
there's a fly ball hit well to left
field abraham almante
moves over and pulls it in crowd number
one
in the air opposite field hit well
naylor going back on the dirt of the
track to make the catch
and back to first goes muncie
1-1 pitch into the shift machado's
coming in from short right throw will be
in time here's dustin may who's 22 years
old out of just in texas making his
third start
that's dribbled left side tatis can
really run so turner's got to get rid of
it quickly and does to get him
to tease the first out of the night as
justin turner's fabulous defensive
season
continues made a grisham 2-2
got him with a cutter two out kicks and
fires another 02
and 99 mile per hour two seam
now the 02 swung on and missed strike
three
95 mile an hour fastball dustin may
has struck out three hitters in a row
here he comes with the payoff pitch
and he strikes him out to finish off the
second with bookend caleb never beat the
dodgers as he heads into tonight's
action
on three in his career against la and a
swing and a miss here for barnes that's
the first strikeout of the night for
nelson lament two down that's a 2-2 fly
to garcia
and right down the middle at 98. garcia
says
uh here's fernando with two outs of he
on first
on the ground and by the first baseman
rios down to the right field corner
mejia racing around they may try and
score him
they will throw coming playwood and
mejia will be
safe at the plate and the padres strike
first on top one and nothing
to third goes tatisse
mejia scores all the way from first with
two down on the padres strike first
everybody's off and running glenn
hoffman you have to send him here with
the stuff that may has tonight you don't
know how many opportunities you're gonna
get
he's got the green light barnes was in
the baseline
that's fair game and mejia knocks him
down
ball is loose and that's a run for san
diego
of course a left-handed batter stands
almost straight up and down the bat
almost
lazily behind his back shoulder swings
at the first pitch skies it to straight
away center grisham jogs in a few steps
waits for it makes the catch at another
very quick one two three inning for
nelson lumet who's through four and has
retired
11 in a row
in the air to right field back goes jack
peterson at the wall and that ball is
gone
home run for jake cronin worth he is
doing it all
in the big league for the first time and
he's got his first big league home run
it's off dustin may and the dodgers and
puts the padres on top two to nothing
from a pitching standpoint lumet has
allowed one base runner
walked to max muncie in the first lined
and caught at first by cronin worth
he goes up and brings it down
this kid is getting it all done
offensively defensively spectacular
some ups right there serious ups
to nelson lumet loves it everybody in a
padre uniform loves it
with two outs a head bassman to walk got
him at first and second and got him in
the air the right side
knocking on out there greg garcia he's
calling off everybody squares up the
home plate
makes a two-hand grab
comes back to get him at 98. that thing
started at his knee and
broke back over the inside corner for
his seventh k which ties a career high
the number of the cutouts and wonderful
charity work
swung on and missed strike three
fastball up and away tatis is down
on strikes your pitch count is down and
you're cruising
with the lead right side cronenworth
will need lumet to cover he does for the
first out of the sixth inning
swinging a miss and he struck him out
fastball at 98.
well it gets bellinger to the plate
representing the tying run
on 1-2 bellinger swings muscles aligner
up the middle and through for the first
hit of the night for the dodgers
breaks up the no-hit bid through five
and two-thirds for denelson lumet
just out of the reach of greg garcia and
bellinger's got the first hit of the
night
another payoff runners go again seeger
slices a base hit into left center to
bring home turner
grisham bobbles the ball bellinger
headed for the plate
here's the throw it is dropped
it's dropped and the game is tied
the kick and the payoff get hard on the
ground
turner stabs it to his feet shows off
the strong arm again
and throws him out aj replaces peterson
who goes oh for three potential go ahead
run at second base
another payoff pollock punches one down
the line to write a base hit to give the
dodgers the lead
aj pollock on his way to second with a
pinch hit
go ahead double and the dodgers take a
three to two lead
first and second one away johnson to
chris taylor
ground ball up the middle into center
field for a base hit
bellinger rounding third he will score
[Applause]
rbi single for chris taylor the dodgers
are up four to two
former dodger manny machado two home
runs so far on the
early going achado may have gone they
check yippee did
chado doesn't like it he's giving ripper
girl
an earful oh he's really good
aj pollock will be leading it off for
the dogs
lifts his spot at center field and
straight away driving grisham back
at the wall there it goes
aj pollack's early season tear continues
a leadoff home run here in the nine
2-2 pitch bounce pass jansen lets it go
by
soccer hernandez can field and throw him
out
an o2 pitch he got him to go on a high
fastball
two gone the set the o2
monte in the air to center field no big
deal for cody bellinger and the dodgers
even this series at a game of peace for
the come from behind
5-2 win over the padres